Welcome to HouseholdHacker.
We're gonna show you how to make a can safe.
You need a can, a little jar, can opener and some hot glue.
Make sure that your aerosol can is completely empty.
And then take the can opener to the bottom, clip it,...
...and spin it around until the bottom cuts off.
Once you're done with that, clean it out.
Remove the nozzle.
Take the lid off your jar...
...and glue it on to the bottom portion of the aerosol can.
Now, take your empty can and stuff it.
You can use anything you want here.
If you want it to be heavier, then use a caulking compound.
We're just going to use some paper towels though.
Then take your jar,...
...put some glue on it,...
...and wrap some more paper towels around it so that it fits snugly inside of the aerosol can.
Push it in.
You're almost set here.
Just throw some hot glue around the edges to make sure it will stay sealed.
Take your lid, screw it in, and you're all set.
Well, it looks like your can safe is finally complete.
You can store anything you want here.
Just be careful that no one sees you making it or the secret will be out.